there is so much happening in the MCU
right now there are so many projects
that are coming to the MCU that
sometimes we forget that Marvel Studios
hasn't actually revealed all of Phase 6
yet now last week we did a video talking
about every confirmed project that we
know is coming from Marvel Studios they
have confirmed these projects themselves
it is the confirmed outline of the
future of the MCU but as I mentioned
there is still a lot more to come as
Marvel Studios has not told us what
exactly is going to be coming in Phase 6
but we've actually heard quite a lot
about what Marvel Studios is planning to
release in Phase 6 and possibly even
more in Phase 5 since we've had a lot of
delays now there's a little bit more
room to add some more special
presentations or Disney Plus shows and
this list that we're going to go over
today of Marvel Studios projects both
movies and shows is over 20 projects
long all of the projects being very very
exciting so the other day we went over
the confirmed schedule today we're going
to go go over the leaked and rumored
projects that are supposed to be coming
from Marvel Studios either in Phase 5 or
Phase 6 and if you love Marvel and the
MCU and want to stay up to date be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the future videos and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series
X some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items we pick a winner at the end of
each month and the winner gets to pick
one item now all of these projects have
been talked about either by insiders or
by big media Outlets like variety or
deadline so they're not just coming out
of nowhere they are coming from decent
sources and for several of these we've
heard that Marvel Studios has already
begun casting for the characters in
these projects so we know a lot of them
are legit we just don't exactly know
when they are coming on the MCU timeline
so these are in no particular order the
first one that we mention isn't going to
be coming first and the last one we
mention won't be last but here's the
entire list of what we know has been
rumored to be coming to the MCU and
we'll start off with the witches Road
this is is going to be somewhat of a
spin-off of the aath the heartness
series and the Scarlet Witch story in
the MCU from what we know about this
it's supposed to be a special
presentation in the MCU and the Scarlet
Witch is supposedly not going to be in
this which is surprising because it's a
big deal for her in the comics she
actually meets her mother there in the
comics it's home to the Scarlet queen
and the witches Road itself is a plane
of existence a realm where only
Sorcerers can go it will be directly
connected to the Scarlet Witch to Agatha
coven of and to Wiccan which leads us
into the next series a Wiccan series
Wiccan is the son of Wanda AKA The
Scarlet witch who we met in Wanda Vision
although when we met him his name was
Billy he is supposed to be returning in
the Agatha coven of chaos series and
then get a spin-off series of his own
according to Daniel rpk this show is
still in development and Marvel Studios
has current plans for this show to lead
directly into a solo Scarlet Witch movie
which of course brings us to the next
project a a solo Scarlet Witch movie
this has been talked about by insiders
for a very long time now it's pretty
much all but confirmed which makes sense
because we're not just going to leave
Wanda's story being what it was the end
of the Scarlet Witch's story in the MCU
isn't going to be well she was bad and
then she kind of became good and then a
mountain fell on top of her Kevin fige
already said if you look closely you can
see a red flash we know she's still
alive she was the strongest character in
the entire probably Multiverse we know
that wouldn't kill her and we can assume
she's going to come back before Avengers
Secret Wars because we assume she's
going to have a pretty decent sized role
in that movie then we know that there
were supposed to be Disney plus series
that were based off of wakanda and it
was confirmed that Ryan cougler was
going to return and direct each of these
projects we know that we have a wakanda
series that is reportedly going to be
animated and then we have an aoi series
now like I mentioned these were
confirmed a long time ago but that could
have changed since then they might not
be doing these anymore we haven't really
heard anything about the AO series
lately but we did hear that the wakanda
series would be animated so they're
probably going through with that and of
course we've heard that they are going
to be making a black panther 3 the
ending of black panther 2 wakanda
forever did set up a new tchala to come
in the MCU this was kind of their
makeshift way of recasting Chadwick
Boseman without recasting Chadwick
Boseman but wakanda is a huge part of
the MCU and it looks like Sheri is going
to continue to hold on to that black
panther mantle probably leading into
Secret Wars because unless they jump
into the future severely with black
panther 3 then the new tchala isn't
going to be old enough to be black
panther yet so we'll assume that Sher
still is the Black Panther for Secret
Wars then we have a Young Avengers film
now this was set up in the Marvels if
you saw the Marvels and you saw the
ending or if you heard about it you know
that they did set up the Young Avengers
in a pretty big way so this is
definitely confirmed we just don't know
when exactly the Young Avengers team is
going to be coming in phase six or if
they decide to wait till after phase six
they could come in Phase 7 however with
the soft reboot who knows what the
situation will be after so I would
assume they're coming in Phase 6 now we
have a lot more to go over including
World War Hulk and a lot more exciting
ones but first big thank you to Highland
titles for sponsoring this video before
we leap back into the world of
superpowers I've got something truly
extraordinary for our Noble listeners
imagine that you yes you can become a
lord or lady for just $30 buying a plot
of land from Highland tile.com will
allow you to make use of a Scottish
tradition in which land owners are given
a courtesy title with more than 15,000
five-star reviews the Highland titles
gift pack is an incredibly popular gift
and the Highland titles app available
from the app and play stores is a new
addition that allows you to explore a 3D
replica of the land choose the location
of your plot and decorate it using
augmented reality embrace the Majesty as
every purchase helps to conserve the awe
inspiring heroic beauty of the Scottish
Wilderness you can soar into the world
of nobility My Friends by visiting
Highland ties.com and become a lord or
lady today use the discount code Cosmic
to receive 25% off your order that's
Highland ties.com and use code Cosmic
now there were two special presentations
that were reported on by many different
insiders that a lot of people were
really excited to get and those two were
a Nova special presentation and a Silver
Surfer special presentation now recently
we have heard that Marvel Studios might
be considering kind of pumping the
breaks on special presentations or might
be switching it up a little bit on how
exactly they format the special
presentation so we're not sure if these
are still a Thing If Marvel is still
planning on doing a Nova and Silver
Surfer special presentation because we
haven't really heard anything about them
for a long time but according to some
insiders Marvel was at least working on
both of these bringing both of these
characters into the MCU giving them
introductions before they go on and
become a part of another film Silver
Surfer for fantastic for maybe Nova for
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 4 who
knows what they'll be in but fingers
crossed that Marvel is still developing
these two projects the next one is Shang
Chi 2 now this one is confirmed and
director Dustin Daniel keton who
directed the first one is supposed to
come back and direct this one as well he
was also supposed to direct Kang Dynasty
although he is not anymore according to
recent reports but from what we've heard
he still involved with other Marvel
projects so shangi 2 is definitely one
that is not canceled we know it's going
to be very important moving forward
before Secret Wars it's going to set up
Secret Wars in a big way and I'm sure
we'll find out more about the 10 rings
and how they are Kang technology and
speaking of director Dustin Daniel keton
he is supposed to be directing the
Wonderman series now we assume this is
officially confirmed because one they
have the director but two they've
actually cast for this movie already
Yaya Abdul matin II is supposed to play
Wonderman so we know this was confirmed
hopefully nothing has changed the only
question I would have is that maybe this
is isn't really a necessary project to
come out before Secret Wars it might not
tie to the story that much so maybe they
wait till phase seven for this but again
we do know this is confirmed we also
have the eternals 2 that is confirmed
now we don't really know much about the
eternals 2 however we do know that of
course Marvel set up a sequel in the
first one Star Fox and pip the troll
showed up and of course the celestials
took a handful of eternals and said that
they were going to judge whether or not
earth should be blown up essentially or
not there obvious viously not going to
avoid that and we're not going to just
ignore that celestials are in the MCU
plus insiders have stated that yes they
are still working on eternals 2 so that
is going to be coming at some point will
it come before Secret Wars or not that's
what we're unsure about right now but if
I had to guess probably phase six and
speaking of sequels of course we have do
strange 3 Doctor Strange 3 is supposedly
going to be based off of the time Runs
Out storyline we know that cleia has
recruited Doctor Strange to help her fix
an incursion that he caused and from
what we we've heard she is going to be a
member of the black priests who are a
multiversal group who is trying to
protect the Multiverse and they have
tracked down a bunch of different doctor
strange variants because he seems to
cause a lot of incursion so they want to
stop our main doctor strange and of
course this is definitely going to be
coming in phase six as it'll be a really
important film building up to Secret
Wars then we have a Hulk solo film
presumed to be World War Hulk According
to some insiders now several different
insid have reported on this and Marvel
Studios has basically told us yes we are
setting it up if you look at everything
they've done so far it seems pretty
obvious Hulk and She-Hulk came back at
the very end with a sun Scar from sakar
and based off of what we know about
Captain America Brave New World they are
still experimenting with super soldier
serum and red Hulk is going to be in
that movie as well and we've heard some
rumors that possibly some other versions
of Hulk will be in this film so it does
seem like they really are building up to
a new Hulk film especially since they
now have the rights to make a solo Hulk
movie so fans are really excited for
that one then there's the Nomad project
we are unsure if this is going to be a
series or movie or if it's even going to
really happen but it's been rumored for
a while now apparently it's going to be
about Captain America returning the
Infinity Stones which we didn't really
see at the end of endgame he has also
rumored to be producing this project
along with Scarlett Johansson which was
confirmed by Marvel she is returning to
produce or direct a project so perhaps
it is this Nomad project and from what
we've heard it will be a multiversal
project so it would fit in there with
Phase 6 however we have to ask how
important would it be of course we want
to see this project but would it fit in
Phase 6 or will this come in Phase 7
then we have Vision Quest this was
confirmed by Marvel Studios but now
we're really unsure again they have said
that they are scaling back on some
Disney plus content so it is possible
that this might get scrapped however we
do have the Spectrum Vision who we met
at the end of one division just out
there somewhere and we assume Marvel
Studios is going to wrap up that story
eventually so at some point in time we
will get a Vision Quest project but like
some of the others it's only a question
of when phase six or phase s we also
heard rumors that a ghost writer special
presentation was in development at
Marvel as well we haven't heard anything
about this in a while but fingers
crossed that we do get this especially
since Marvel Studios is going into the
more darker side of the MCU and speaking
of that it's been rumored that we are
going to be getting a midnight Suns
project and this would be fantastic with
blade and everybody entering the MCU
having a midnight Suns team with blade
Deadpool moonight the Black Knight Ghost
Rider The Punisher who is coming in the
Daredevil Series this would just be an
epic project and I can't wait till
Marvel Studios finally releases it and
speaking of moonnight Insider Daniel rbk
has recently said that Marvel Studios is
discussing a moonnight season 2 and a
Miss Marvel season 2 these would most
most definitely come before the end of
phase six as both of these characters
will probably play a really important
role for the story of Secret Wars we did
a video on this yesterday you can check
that out if you want we mentioned this
in the other video we did but armor Wars
is confirmed it was a series and now
it's a movie we just have no idea when
this project is going to be coming out
but we assume phase six although Marvel
did really confuse us with roie being a
scroll in secret Invasion so I think a
lot of fans really are eager to see this
project and last but not least one that
we know is confirmed right now is Thor 5
as sad as it is this will probably be
the last Thor Solo movie that we get of
course he'll return in Avengers Secret
Wars and hopefully he'll see Loki and
see what Loki has become and the
sacrifice that he made and we have heard
that taoa Titi who directed Thor
Ragnarok and Thor love and thunder will
not be returning to Direct Thor 5 but
those are the projects that have been
rumored for a while now some of them are
confirmed like I said but keep in mind
since Marvel Studios and Disney are
changing things up a bit internally some
of these could be scrapped and there
could be some projects coming that we
have absolutely no idea about which I
honestly hope is the case I hope they
surprise us with some awesome projects
but go ahead and let me know what you
are most excited for out of all of these
projects that we talked about in this
video leave your thoughts in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on the MCU don't forget to
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof